please welcome two Academy Award
nominated actors John Travolta and Queen
Latifah
boy I love when Broadway musicals become
big hot Hollywood movies like dream
girls but Chicago or the one we just
made that we can't talk about hmm and I
love a full-figured woman who can stand
in front of a camera and sing her heart
out but that's enough about me
here's a recap for the nominees for Best
Original Song from An Inconvenient Truth
I need to wake up music and lyric by
Melissa Etheridge from dream girls
listen music by Henry Krieger and Scott
Cutler lyric MA and brother
from Dreamgirls love you I do music by
Henry Krieger lyric watsuhita Gary from
cars our town music and lyric by Randy
Newman
from Dreamgirls patients music and lyric
by Henry no music by Henry Krieger lyric
by Willy reali and the Oscar goes to
Melissa Etheridge for I need to wake up
from Inconvenient Truth Melissa
Etheridge's road to the Oscars began
with a very simple philosophy of life be
strong
speak true and spread the peace
wow that feels as good as you think it
does I I have to thank my incredible
wife Tammy and our four children Beckett
and Bailey and Johnny Rosa Miller and um
everyone I've ever worked with just
thank you I love you you know and all
the incredible people that worked on
this film and gave so much but mostly I
have to thank Al Gore for inspiring us
inspiring me showing that caring about
the earth is not Republican or Democrat
it's not red or blue we are all green
this is our job now we can become the
greatest generation the generation that
changed the generation that woke up and
did something and changed I love you
home Thank You Academy this is great